hey guys i'm justin and i'm sitting here
with simon on rift development team rift
Oh Simon what is your exact title or
whatever what is your role on the
rippetoe almighty I am what's called a
development director so the design team
report to me and I sort of like make
sure that they stay on track and get
stuff done however I also get the
privilege of actually putting a lot of
stuff into the game as well I've always
loved that aspect of my job so I get to
make stuff and work alongside an amazing
group of people and ripped certainly not
a new MMO but there's a lot of big new
exciting content coming in the first one
here is this the Starfall expansion
stoffel prophecy yes this is our second
big expansion actually a third big
expansion but we've always had an
extremely fast pace of putting new
content into the game so even between
expansions we've added new zones and
things like that so over the I guess six
years now that rift has been out the
world has got very much bigger and it's
about to get much bigger again this as
you are looking at here is the initial
quest hub of startled prophecy which is
five big new zones another four levels
for players to adventure through as well
as several new systems that we're
introducing this time as well so the
reason it's empty of course this is not
out to the public yet this is a nice
development server that's right it
actually launches next week but what
you're seeing here is yes is our
development server so you're not going
to see any other players running around
and we're running on a laptop but that I
think that also speaks to what in the
most have to be these days these are
things that can run on a wide variety
machines that's right the we you know
you're seeing it here with maybe
an average sort of look you can set the
settings a lot lower if your machine is
not as powerful as this laptop or you
can set them higher if it's a lot more
powerful so so as an expansion it's
going to be friendly for people who
definitely have not played for a long
time maybe they started out or who were
playing for the first five year you're
introducing a immediate level cap rise
right or not yes well knock out better
jump right you if you want to jump
straight in and try out the new
expansion you can level yourself to the
bottom level of the expansion which is
level 65 so there will be an immediate
jump to level 65 if you wish we work
hard in trying to make rift accessible
to people jumping in it's a challenge in
MMOs at the best of times but we have
various things like presets so that your
character is preset up with all of the
abilities and stuff like that so you
should be able to jump in and start
going right away yeah thinking about of
course the other big MMO out there world
of warcraft it we had blizzcon not too
long ago and they were also talking
about their next patch the Legion
expansion that why it came out and
they're definitely a MMO that's aimed at
bringing in new people and continuing to
streamline what can be a very
complicated process is that kind of a
route that ripped is going long as well
as it trying to cater more to that park
war in an opamp or I mean LMO is a
really unique type of game I think in
fact the fact that there are so many
different types of players that play
them you know you'll have the really
hardcore people that want to have an
extremely high challenge and will
probably gravitate towards the raids and
things like that and then you have the
the other end other extreme where
they're far more casual and so all mmos
trying rift is absolutely no exception I
think we actually do this really well
which is actually cater to a lot of
those two
groups there were stuff here for the
really hardcore we have some seriously
hard raids and dungeons and we actually
I know just by reading our forums and
various other sources that people like
the challenge that we still have in rift
it's not sort of like completely melba
toast where you hit a button and bam i
won it is there were definitely
challenges but then we also have this
amazing stuff for the casual players
like our dimension system absolutely
best-in-class housing I mean there is
nothing else like it you can actually
our housing is just an understatement
because it's not really house and you
get to have a little slice of the world
and you can don't decorate it with just
literally thousands of different objects
I've seen people actually do scenes from
from Star Wars and various other movies
just just absolutely incredible their
creativity of the players and in that
particular aspect as you can see here
we're going through various different
wardrobe outfits again just a very
robust wardrobe system it actually
becomes a bit of a collecting game
you're trying to collect all of the
possible wardrobes that are various on
the collecting games so it it caters
from the very casual to the pretty
hardcore and pretty much everything in
between so always a bit of a challenge
but also really good fun so thinking
about players who maybe haven't played
for a long time or getting players over
who are maybe done with what they've
done in World of Warcraft Legion what is
it that's going to draw that over to ask
our whole prophecy well I mean I think
one of the first things is just how
incredibly beautiful it looks I'm in our
art team have absolutely outdone
themselves every time I seem to find
myself saying mad a lot whenever we're
putting out a new expansions like wow
our art team did an even better job than
they did last time out and they can't
seem to keep watching it up and up and
up so some beautiful areas to explore
you will find a really nice community to
be part of that are for the majority of
look
will be very helpful and will help you
get into the game and explain things to
you there is a again we've tried to make
it very accessible to get in you can get
in at a fairly you know sort of scratch
the surface sort of level and have a
really good fun time doing some of the
quests but the further you get into rift
you'll find that there are it's like an
onion in a way you can do as more and
more things to find I mean we have a an
incredibly deep what we call the Sol
system which is basically your class and
how your character plays you get to mix
and match abilities beyond anything i
think that people are used to before in
any other games again we we give you
presets here that make it easy to get
into but if you once you've got got used
to that you can then start delving into
the nuances of this and really build up
your character to play exactly how you
want it to play you know we kind of
broke the mold in a way for instance we
have healing mages tanking rogues you
know just things that people are not
really used to those tend to be a little
bit more advanced features but you know
yet there's also all of the standard
stuff there to to sort of get into at
first I never sue with an expansion and
a little cap that players are also going
to have more abilities for each of their
classes to explore right what we did
actually this time is rather than just
add a whole ton more abilities that you
know just like increasing that this is
called psaltery rather than just adding
new abilities to this what we did is we
picked some of the key abilities of each
of the souls each one of these things as
a soul some of the more fun ones and
iconic ones of that soul and in you as
you go up in levels you will get what a
call to legendary points and you can
then turn one of the abilities that
you're used to in to a legendary version
of that ability and they are game
changers they are absolutely
they'd turn your character into just the
most powerful crazy thing though I mean
an example might be the rogue here that
we're playing one of the abilities they
have is it's called sidesteps it makes
you it makes you just almost unhittable
for a certain period of time one of the
legendary abilities allows you to recast
that instantly again so you can actually
extend that ability out longer and you
can become almost invincible with about
40 seconds or so and you can do a lot of
damage in that time thorough and just
generally you will find that it will
change that your rotation you will find
that you're playing differently because
you have these new legendary abilities
we've been having a heck of a lot of fun
around the office just seeing what we
can do with these things it's going to
be quite the balancing act because if
anything they are bordering on game
breaking right now but that is also
really good fun that's what we want is
we want people to feel like oh my god I
am just completely Opie now what are
these crazy people thinking and it's
just really good fun I can't wait to see
what the players come up with the bills
that they come up with and the things
lives oh nice one quits before down that
hole so that's that yes that's the way
players are going to get more powerful
in store for prophecy yeah this is the
big bad bad actually honestly the tower
here that you can see is actually
sentient and is the sort of light center
of the story and sorry I own clubs are
you a little respect on the fly well it
depends what you mean by that you can
respect completely in other words kind
of like kind of changed my whole you
know so let's start again oh and then
you can actually save out versions that
you like and you can then switch between
those preset bills that you've decided
that you like yes not quite on the fly
just any time you're out of combat which
is next on the fly
in fact you will find that as I was
speaking about earlier some of the
hardcore raids you will find that if you
are on a raid you might find that your
raid leader is asking you to at least
have three or four different specs
available that you can change into at
different points during the raid so you
might not just play the same thing
through the entire raid you might find
that you need to hey I need everybody to
you know switch over to their dps spec
for this particular flight I'm going to
need the tanks to you know maybe do a
little bit of extra heal and this you
know things like that so it and there's
definitely a lot going on when you when
you introduce the ability to jump
straight into the game at not max level
but but near that how are you either
reintroducing it to players who haven't
played for a long time or bringing new
players up to speed is there a tutorial
section how does that work well I think
that will be done mainly by the quests
that you go on but particularly the
first zone that you are guided towards
skater and forest that was the there's
going to like pretty green area we're in
earlier they will definitely ease you
into the game I'm not gonna pretend that
you know jumping in at level 65 is quite
going to give you the depth of knowledge
about your class that's starting at
level 1 and working your way up through
65 would I think that you would find
somebody that actually decides you know
what I'm gonna enjoy the full rift
experience and actually start at level
one of which you know there's a lot of
great content in there for them to
explore doing that they will probably
have a better feel for their character
than somebody that jumps in at level 65
but by the time you have played up
through the five new levels up to level
70 would probably know your class pretty
much as well as anyone else by that
point what other kinds of new content
stop all privacy issues well one of the
new things I mean what I mean obviously
what players want in an expansion as
well as new areas to explore and I think
just by looking at the visuals that have
been going on here you can see that that
is absolutely glorious but there is also
they want new power we talked a little
bit about that with the legendary
abilities but also new stuff new
equipment and we also kind of like tore
up the book with this a new feature as
well rather than actually just kind of
hey look here's a new breastplate and
you need to find the one that's good for
the tank or here's a new pair of boots
that's good for a mage we are actually
introducing this time something called
plane of fragments so we moved quite a
few of the secondary ability that power
steps rather off of the equipment that
you find they will still have their base
stats but the secondary stats like
blocking or attack power or spell power
and now actually put on these things
called planar fragments which you can
equip on top of your armor and these
will actually provide you with new stats
and you can then upgrade these you can
break down old ones that you don't like
so much into new things that then are
used to upgrade the ones that you do
like and you can really start tailoring
your equipment to fit the class that you
have decided to build so it puts rather
than having to go and do a raid 400
times hoping that that one ress plate
that you've been looking for actually
drops this puts a little bit more of the
power into the players hands to start
tailoring any equipment they find
towards what they want it to be there
were definitely still some random
elements in here the the higher the
value of the plane of fragment that you
find the higher the rarity the more
stats it's going to have and the more
things you can unlock so there is
definitely still that anticipation game
of will I get a good one versus do i it
is this just junk I'm going to break
down is you know it's still that I mean
we don't want to get rid of the fun
parts of that that
sort of like oh my god I got something
awesome but we want to be L say well I
got something awesome and now I can make
it more awesome it's like you know yeah
pretty pretty cool I think a big thing
that you see in with some other of the
Mo's when you come up on an expansion is
generally new classes or new new braces
to play as is that something that the
team thought about it all for this
ripped attention and not for this one
actually the last we didn't call it us
an expansion we have only ever called
things that increased level cap
expansions however I would go as far as
saying that the last thing that we put
out which was plain touch wilds was
about as close as you can get to an
expansion without being an expansion it
was a huge new zone there was a whole
ton of new stuff and we actually at that
point introduced a new calling as we
call that which is the fundamental base
class like rogue mage warrior cleric we
introduced the prime a list which was a
whole new way of playing we didn't do
that this time you know that's not to
say that we wouldn't do things like that
going forward there was just you know
it's like you've got it when you first
start deciding what are you going to put
into an expansion the list is massive
and you have only so much time and I'm
so much people to actually do stuff so
you decide what are going to be the core
things we want to do what's going to be
the most fun and that was just one of
the things that we decided we've just
done that let's not do that again for
this expansion and one other thing I'll
point out here chris is rushing around
in this world has aggro turned off so
that's why nothing is attacking him it's
also why everything's not naturally a
running after and murdering him so I own
a memo is of course a living thing
although it's a game that's constantly
changing it and constantly growing like
what is the roadmap post the expansion
are there you guys have patches lined up
or a story you're no ABS absolutely i
mean i mean we have we have stuff mapped
out for rift going far into the future
obviously the further into the future
you go a little bit more likely it is to
change but
we have stuff that is planned and
basically ready to be coming out right
after this actually Chris can you just
pull up that the map limit work yeah
just the map a second so upper up at the
oh you're not in the world never mind
don't don't even and so we have a new
zone that is basically ready to go that
we will be putting out soon after launch
we have a new raid coming soon after
launch we have my personal opus which is
a puzzle dungeon that's going to be
coming out after all so that's going to
be something that's kind of unique to
rift because a lot of times a raid is
about kind of like destroying giant
great big monsters there's always been
this exploration element to rift I've
played MMOs ever since MMOs were
invented basically and one of the things
I would always do and I found that many
other players do as well is they will
try and get somewhere weird that you
know it's like I climbed up this
freaking melton that I'm sure I wasn't
supposed to do I bet the developers
didn't know I could get here and then it
was like okay well that was good what am
I going to do now and I guess I'm going
to go back now but what what rift has
done is we have various different ways
that we actually try and reward the
players for doing that kind of thing we
have artifacts that they might find up
there on top of that mountain or way
down at the bottom of some ocean and
plus puzzles they might come across some
weird little puzzle they have to saw and
get some prize for and what's coming
soon is we actually decided we were
going to make an entire dungeon of those
so there is a dungeon where you pretty
much don't fight anything you just saw
some crazy earth puzzles and get some
really nice prizes at it that way the
challenge is as long and as rewarding as
doing a long raid encounter but it is
for a completely different type of
player group so anyway that's kind of
like a rambling answer to do we have new
stuff planned yes we've got a ton of
southland and a ton of wishes and wants
and things that we would love to get
around to doing more than probably could
get done in the lifetime but we'll keep
going for a long time man what do you
think they'll be most excited about in
store for us ah that's such a tough
question that's why asking me to choose
my favorite child I do so I don't know
and I flip-flop on this depending on
what I'm doing when I'm playtesting or
what I tend to have this thing of when
I'm playtesting is like this is my
favorite feature but as I said a little
bit ago I think I'm really looking
forward to seeing what players do with
the legendary abilities and the builds
they come up with incorporate some of
these new game changing things it's
going to be really interesting to see so
I think they will love the legendary
abilities I think it's a bit of a longer
thing to get into but I think they will
start really enjoying the plane of
fragments to particularly as they start
building them up to higher levels and
they start having significant effects on
their survivability and I'm sure
everybody knows what dps is are there
any other [ __ ] what I will cut this up
a little bit so it shud there are there
any other one hitter make sure the
really well i mean the i think i pretty
much covered the really big big things i
would like to mention though that there
are and just as we have always done all
of the systems that players are already
used to in rift have all been expended
out to accommodate the level 70 you get
your crafting systems we didn't even
touch on that but I know that that's
another huge group of players that love
to craft and do all that kind of stuff
fishing we have survival at another sort
of crafting ability we have dimensions I
slightly touched on all of those systems
also extend it out and have new things
for players to find so
I like to think that we have provided a
little bit of something for all of the
various groups of players that we have
in rift so rich stock or proxy is coming
out next week that's right d what's this
specific date 16 I wasn't sure whether
i'll have to say yes yes november 16 is
that would be wednesday it is how much
how much there were two versions the
prices I'm little offer from about
twenty nine ninety nine and no idea
Serena we don't they yeah go to riff
gamecom they are I think for what
players are going to get and absolutely
reasonable we've got to keep the lights
on somehow love you so we have it I know
yes is 39 yeah is this point where it's
very nice ignite 39 5939 59 so 59 what
you know what you get with it 59 with
the higher one you and you get a show
you get an amazing outfit you get an
amazing mount and you get a title you
get Chris help me out here I know
there's a bunch more on Miss getting
Idol you get an awesome celestial Drake
and you get a really cool culture frame
the portrait right Mike I believe we're
using right here but the dates are in
the way those are natural I can work
this fool will try that one or two just
make it kind of a cleaner okay in a
structure but hang on though because so
I just make sure I get everything then
that's okay that's on top of the molten
40 a happy she ate that too but I can't
agree right all right help how much just
breathe okay yeah right so does rip
several prophecy is coming out next week
I think November 16th that's right and
this is this is a paid expansion of
course and it has two different tears
that's right it has the standard edition
as we're calling it which is a I believe
39 59 something like that and then we
have the $59 version that gives you a
few extra perks gives you
an incredible-looking mount but a
celestial Drake it gives you this outfit
that you can see right here which for
long time players are if they've been
asking for forever which is the Asha
qatari rainy we call it a trick Atari is
one of the key characters in rift and
literally I think since she was
introduced way back at launch people
have been asking for this outfit it
gives you a portrait frame that's
another thing that players get to
customize on their character it gives
you a title the star lady or star-lord
and some other things I'm trying
forgetting one other thing you asked
that I would like to mention there's
other things that we've been continually
doing since the launch of rift is
improving the technology we just
recently actually introduced multi-core
back in the day when riff launched
multi-core was something that was
available it wasn't sort of like widely
used it wasn't something that we went
out the door with it has become a
standard thing on most pcs now so we
went back and retooled the engine to
support for multi-core and just recently
in fact is still in beta but is going to
go live with this wench from the 64-bit
versions so for 64-bit support as well
so as well as doing all of the fun new
content and new monsters and you know
featuring systems and things like that
we want to make sure that the foundation
of rift stays current as well so we
continue to work on the technology
little bit more invisible to players but
benefits all players across the ball so
what's of an exciting new content thank
you so much for stopping by in what can
you suicide you are most welcome
you